Ah, love.
You gotta love it. Everywhere you look, there
it is.
But in the city that never sleeps. How do you
really know who the hell you're sleeping with?
People can conceal some very dirty secrets.
Or fatally fatal flaws.
Everything's fine.
Joy is just loudly shattering sea glass to put in
her aquarium.
Sure, sure. Sure.
Uhh, have you asked your new fiance about the lipstick yet?
Did she write "f*cking pig" on Ben's dressing room mirror?
Yeah. No, but I will.
Charles, you said you would ask her two days
ago. Let us in. We could talk to her.
I am handling the situation in my own time.
See, I told you he didn't need our help, but
I do. Does this scarf say "Loretta, I've loved
you since the first day I met you"?
I don't know what the scarf is saying, but
all I could see is a crayon box.
Oh, well, see, that's why we always carry a
backup. Thank you, Mabel.
Charles, I can calmly talk to Joy, you know,
investigator woman to suspect woman.
She is not another Jan. Well, she could be.
But it's important for me to be able to
interrogate my murderous girlfriend... Fiance?
Shit.
What about my hair? Is it giving Karen or
Cary Grant?
Hold on, Mabel Mora...
Are you going out on a date?
Date?
No, no, no, Tobert has a suspect he has a lead on.
I'm meeting him for a stakeout, and the place has a dress code.
Well, it's a date.
Yeah.
It's a stakeout. When two totally
platonic, semi-professional investigators
wait together in an out-of-sight enclosed
space and watch while a suspect hopefully
incriminates themselves while we hold in our
pee for hours and eat stale Cheetos.
In a cocktail dress.
Look, I'm gonna unmute your text. I'll be in
the wings if anything should go haywire.
I'll be okay.
Is it possible you're sleeping next to a
lunatic or a liar? Sure it is. But I always
tell people, better lose your mind loving
than to live your life loveless.
It's been a while since I dipped my quill in
a woman's ink pot. Any new moves I should
know about?
Please don't make me take the next one.